And now let's go back here. So let's review the answer.
So we already said that for the first machine we able
to express it this way. We would say x sub 1 has a mean
of three standard deviation 3.1. Second machine has slightly higher
mean average but lower standard deviation.
and these are
this is where we want the experiments to fall between
so let's continue.
We then plug in the numbers, right? So this used
to be a
this and of
course, this is the mean standard deviation. This is B.
Standard deviation means that deviation if
plot in those numbers into the what
do you call it?
the five function
so
Let's see what these numbers out of two before because I want
to show you these Z table first.
So this gives us five of one.
Anyway, this this becomes 5 of 1.
And this becomes Phi of
negative 1.
So when you when you like evaluate this
this fraction you get
One this one gives you minus one
if we look up the z-score the
Z table for the z-score table.
You will see that the you will find these.
Probabilities in that table. So let's go
that table. Here's the link. We'll click here.
you get
0.158
66 that's what we have here.
And then for positive 1
where is positive 1?
positive 1 you get
Yeah, there we go.
0.84
so you see even though those machines had
their own mean and their own standard deviation and you will come
across different.
A problems where you know you'll have a normally distributed random
variable continuous random variable.
It doesn't matter what the me, I mean.
even if you have different mean and different standard deviation once you normalize
it
Once you normalize it using the techniques we've looked at
now.
then
it's it becomes easy to then calculate calculate the
probability. In fact, the only way you can calculate the probability.
The only way you can determine whether it's between 0 or 1.
Is for you to take that random variable transform a
shift its me to zero.
Look up the Z score and then you will get the probability. So anyway.
We calculate the area.
for
standard deviation to the negative because that's what
this adds up to this evaluates into.
and the
area for
Excuse me, the area for positive one of minus 1.
this is the probability for
positive 1 this is probably from minus 1 you subtract
them because your point six eight two six. So this
means
that the probability
that this machine the first machine, this is
z sub 1 by the way.
The first machine will produce quarks.
That would be their 2.9 or 3 2.9 or
three or three point one or somewhere between that small.
Acceptable range is 0.6826.
It's like 68% chance 68% probability.
That you would get the correct size.
Now is that acceptable?
When we're looking at the notation alone.
When we were looking at the notation alone.
You know, we could have been fooled by this.
the fact that this is right, you know,
it's like
like it's directly three. It's what I just want us towards the
upper end.
And we could have thought you know what maybe this has a better mean maybe
this could be this could be good. But then when we
take into account the standard deviation
We determine that has a 68%
68% probability
that it's coax will be at the right size.
Okay.
Let's compare it against the other one.
So we do the same thing.
This is z sub 2 by the way, even if you don't see the subscript it
is the sub two.
So we take x x sub 2 we standardize it
we shifted some into the zero.
and then we want to see if it falls between 3.1 or
2.9
Of course. We also have to standardize these numbers.
So we can evaluate.
There's a score so we do the same
thing where we subtract the numerator from the mean divide all
divided by the standard deviation.
And then of course we use the five function to measure.
the
cumulative probability
to measure the cumulative probability using the integration technique
I told you about
this adds up to three.
If we look up the z-score.
If you look up the z-score for three.
this comes back to that the rule I told
you earlier about 68 95 99.7 rule,
so
Once down to deviation you get 68 probably 0.68
probability two standard deviations.
You have much higher probability. Now you're at 95.
Three standard deviations of a probability distribution
you have 99.7 probability so highly highly
highly likely that those experiments will occur.
So if we go down this table and look for three.
It's actually goes up to 3.9.
But at 3, it's 99.
It's a 0.998675 very high.
Okay.
and then
we plot that we put that number down.
On the negative side on the negative side.
This goes actually up to
like
this fraction evaluated to
negative 7.
Evalu to negative 7. So that's
minus 7
standard deviations away
now
once you move past minus 3 standard deviation
the part of positive side, there are three standard deviations the negative
side. The probability is almost it's almost
one. So this is negative seven and if I take it back to
the z-score table
one doesn't go past minus 3.9 but you
can see when it's at 3.9 is 0.005 and
as you
Add to this like as you go towards
the left.
Of the third standard deviation. The number
gets smaller and smaller and smaller and like
and smaller
So that is why I have rounded like I've rounded
this up to 0.0.0.01 or one
it's actually even smaller than this.
So if we subtract
the probability
from the positive side
subtracted from the negative side. We actually get a big.
We get a lot of coverage. In fact, it's 99.8.79.9987.
So the probability that the second machine would produce quarks.
That have diameter between 3.9.
And 2.9 and 3.1 and 2.9 is
9 9 8 7.
almost 1
Almost 100%
Almost 100% of the corks produced by the second
machine will fall in the correct range.
the other one
68.6826
much lower
much more susceptible to
you know.
producing failed quarks corks that are not usable
so I mean
that's like 0.3 or 30% probability
that you produce a coconut use it so that's
Imagine that we were talking about something besides quarks.
How much waste how much?
Would that cost you a great deal?
well
using the techniques that we've looked at we were able to determine that. In
fact, the second machine is much better.
and the first machine